[Music]
such a st. Petersburg bridge that hardly
anyone outside the city has heard of but
now news of it is dividing Russians the
pro-kremlin TV station NTV welcome to
proposal to name it the Kitty Roth
bridge an idea the critical broadcaster
doosh finds laughable relate at all to
mr. Qadir off to st. Petersburg and vice
versa it doesn't but it just goes to
show what he is able to do don't we just
rename the palace square right now let's
be generous it's all about this man
Ahmed Kadir of the first president of
Chechnya and father of today's Chechnya
leader Ramzan Kadyrov in the 1990s
Russia waged the bloody war against
Chechnya one of its own Federal
republics at that time kadhi Roth was an
Islamic leader calling for holy war
against the Russians later he changed
sides but he didn't tone down his
extremist views it said you once claimed
if every Chechen killed 150 Russians he
would make it to paradise no in the mid
90s I told the Chechens to kill as many
Russians as possible I didn't say how
many and just as many as they could it's
no secret that I called for jihad the
war is past but it's far from forgotten
as the current dispute about the bridge
shows
in 2003 akhmad Kadyrov change from a
separatist to Chechnya first pro-russian
president Russia has a history of naming
streets city squares and even bridges
for political reasons local people like
here in Moscow rarely get to say in the
matter
but this bridge for example right behind
me where the Russian politician Boris
Nemtsov was killed more than a year ago
a brazen clearly political murder of the
most well known opposition leader in
Russia that prompted hundreds of
thousands people to call the authorities
to name this bridge the Nemtsov bridge
but without any result
Nemtsov and Qadir of senior have little
in common except that both were killed
by extremists qadir of son Ramzan is
suspected of having pulled the strings
behind themselves murder many Muscovites
are angry that a bridge will bear the
Kadir of name that's terrible why he's
not my hero catch me as hero lots of
respect for Kadir of he does many good
things and if st. Petersburg wants to
honor his father
maybe that will bring Russia and
Chechnya closer together awkward though
many here think that's unlikely and
they've taken their protests to the
streets of st. Petersburg their last
hope is that the city's mayor will
refuse to rename the bridge after Kadir
of senior